okay i've been wanting to do like a
dedicated lesson on this for a while
because this is a kind of a new opening
trap
that i've tried playing in a few games
i haven't really fully explained but
maybe i'll explain
it and i'll show why it's like it's so
dangerous
especially for unsuspecting players it's
relatively secret
i have been trying to play it i know i
explained it a few times
but it starts as a queen's pawn opening
d4
e5 d takes e5
and now in this position i mean the main
move by far
is knight c6 but the trappy line
emerges after bishop c5 so the fifth
most popular move
is still played over 25 000 times
and now from this position we're gonna
follow all of white's most popular moves
and this is why the trap is so
incredible
it is because white's gonna just play
like the most common move
if we go down like three or four more
moves white will fall into the trap
so knight of three now here we play d6
e takes d6 most common move
and now knight e7 this is so beautiful
knight e7 and again most common move
is d takes e7 so if you were to play
this line
statistically white is most likely
to go down this variation
and the whole point i should explain
after 97
pawn takes e7 we lost a knight but we
win the queen with bishop f2
and this is why black is scoring very
very high here
bishop takes f2 420 people have gotten
this as black
the trick is to pre-move knee seven to
seem like a blunder
exactly so i'm gonna get to that but uh
yeah we
take take and take and we were up a
queen
sawfish gave like minus almost four here
so it's really really beautiful um
it's it's still like relatively unknown
uh
i first saw this in like one of these
twitch
it was like a twitch highlights reel
where
another streamer gm derrick trapped
nereditsky in this line
um let's do this
fall for it
someone clipped that someone clipped
that please
and the key as brian mentioned
after pawn dig z6 actually so when you
play d6
the key is then to pre-move knight e7
so when white takes knight e7 is played
instantly
white will think it's just like a
accidental pre-move mouse slip
and white won't even think twice about
not taking it even though white
has played some other moves um
just according to the stats white is
most likely to take here
assuming people haven't uh haven't seen
my
my past uh games in this
so d takes e7 and then we win the queen
and there are a few variations of this
um imagine white plays bishop f4 here
we can still set up the trap if white
plays bishop f4 keep in mind you'll
you'll have pre-moved knight e7
then if you get to this position i
recommend
pre-moving knight c6
again you're hoping white takes imagine
what it takes
you pre-move knight c6 we should know
white actually has
two different captures both of which
lose the queen to bishop takes f2
obviously this
this opening is not meant for serious
play it's kind of a one
of one-time trick if white like if white
doesn't fall for it
i mean e3 is the second most popular
and then then you're down upon
um but okay it's still playable and
maybe there's some like
uh risk analysis where
it's worth taking the risk in the event
that a lot of people fall into it
and black can still have have
counterplay here maybe bishop g4
um i think i've i've had something
similar to this a few times
where i'll i'll play this setup in
castle queen side and then just attack
on the king's side
so what i might end up doing is just
put together like a a compilation of
every time i've had this because i've
had this in
maybe five or six games and i'll try and
put together everything in the youtube
video
i'm gonna ban you and you're probably
not gonna do anything right is that the
these are the stakes here
i think so yeah no if i beat you i ban
you
and if i beat you then i mean i would
feel bad
doing anything negative so maybe i'll
okay yeah perfect i'll give you a shout
out or something
oh you play d4 ah got him
we got him okay i'll cheat this is a
weird whatever thing
[Music]
there goes your queen let's try and
do something
[Music]
there goes my queen that's the whole
point of this opening just to win the
queen
life goes on
ah my knights ah there goes white's
queen
it's such a nice chat the second time
the stream this has happened
ah my knights ah okay
there goes white's queen
another victim to the trap this is maybe
the third time in the stream
[Music]
okay this one again
[Music]
opponent perplexed
oh i've never had someone take someone
oh my knight no
oh no
there goes white's queen
hey it's gm derrick gm derek
i hope you're not too broken i'm sharing
i'm kind of sharing this trick it's such
a good trick if this goes on youtube
i'm linking gm derek's twitch channel
people should check him out
for amazing bullet content shout out gm
derrick
gm derek where did you learn this from
you said you you saw it from another
person right
a friend oh a friend and i made it up oh
wow
okay so this is a gm derrick trap
and gm derrick's friend i think this is
going to be the next big thing
until it maybe dies now g and derek says
i trick a lot of
28 and 2900 players on chess.com with
bullets
oh wait let's see
let's fact check okay
so we're gonna we're gonna analyze the
founder or maybe the co-founder of this
trap
and see like how many strong players
he's trapped
okay so uh as black d4
e5 uh-oh do you take c5
let's go six people got trapped
one person won yeah that's the nature of
bullets
so i'm just seeing white's rating so
rated 2300
oh this is an ereditsky game oh
nerditsky drew
aha yeah a few other high rated players
as well
[Music]
and then like um this doesn't include
like bishop f4 instead
like there's a lot of different
transpositions which can happen
so another fun fact if you play
england gabit and let's say you play
staff or gambit
you could potentially pre-move e5 on
move one
the only issue is knight f3 if knight f3
you
you pre-move e5 this is uh this is
actually a walrus
after it takes you play knight c6
this is uh the beloved walrus
and the cool thing about the walrus if
white plays e4 here
you transpose into a stafford gambit
leachate still thinks this is a walrus
but this is a the main staff or gamut
position
so again this is not something
to play in like serious uh
classical tournament play but for blitz
and bullet online
against unsuspecting competition
um i think it's it's so venomous